parce que notre ville se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' équilibre votre
magazine sur l'environnement ce mois ci
nous aborderons le thème de la
transition énergétique
aujourd'hui chez les énergies fossiles
représentent 70% votre consommation
d'énergie le nucléaire 75% entre
consommation d'électricité ces énergies
sont très polluantes et coûteront très
cher à l'avenir afin de préserver
l'environnement et notre porte-monnaie
le devons changer nos habitudes pour en
parler nous partirons à magny les
hameaux rencontré antoine désir qui a
rénové son pavillon pour en faire une
maison très basse consommation nous
irons ensuite à la maison de
l'environnement de saint quentin avec
franck sentiers directeur de l'alec afin
de connaître les conseils à suivre pour
rénover écologiquement son habitat met
tout de suite rendez vous à paris avec
bernard laponche expert en maîtrise de
l'énergie interview
monsieur laponche merci beaucoup de ne
recevoir chez vous ici à paris première
question la transition énergétique est
ce que c'est une idée écologistes ou
aujourd'hui c'est véritablement
indispensable
et côté c'est une obligation mondiale la
plupart des états l'ont compris
alors que ce soit mis des écologistes
oui mais mais c'est une idée qui
s'imposent pour des raisons de
protection de l'environnement et des
raisons économiques la consommation
d'énergie ne cesse d'augmenter au niveau
mondial elle repose beaucoup sur des
combustibles des énergies de stock c'est
à dire les combustibles fossiles charbon
pétrole gaz et l'uranium qui ont des
ressources limitées
le prix du pétrole augmente sans cesse
et donc à une pression économique que
l'on ressent au niveau de la facture
coût de l'énergie pour les ménages en
plus la population mondiale augmente et
donc on ne peut pas tenir à ce rythme on
sait très bien ce qu'il faut faire ce
soit dans les bâtiments dans l'industrie
dans l'espoir on en ont fait un peu donc
ce n'est pas rien mais on pourrait en
faire beaucoup plus et ceux beaucoup
plus est est nécessaire parce que vous
pouvez pas supporter une économie qui
continue à dépenser tellement pour son
énergie en particulier en importation le
nucléaire aujourd'hui peut-on vraiment
s'en passer monsieur la poche
alors au niveau mondial le nucléaire
représente très peu ils représentent 10%
de la production d'électricité ce qui
est pas grand chose et qui est peu connu
à comparer à 20% pour les énergies
renouvelables donc déjà si vous voulez
il ya la possibilité on voit bien qu'à
la possibilité globalement de remplacer
le nucléaire par les énergies
renouvelables et par les économies
d'électricité pour la france c'est plus
compliqué parce que 75% de la production
d'électricité vient du nucléaire mais
sur une durée d'une vingtaine d'années
ça peut se faire mais ça peut se faire à
condition d'une part de reconnaître que
cette cette utilisation d'énergie
nucléaire est extrêmement dangereuse à
cause du risque d'accident puisqu'on a
vu déjà three mile island tchernobyl
faux shima donc on ne peut plus dire que
ce n'est pas possible et donc
faut-il garder cette technique alors
qu'elle est si dangereuse tout ça pour
produire de l'électricité alors qu'on
peut produire de l'électricité avec bien
d'autres choses et deuxièmement il ya la
question des déchets radioactifs ils
sont dangereux pendant des centaines et
des milliers d'années on ne peut pas
actuellement pas de moyens de les
transformer et leurs rollers stockage
pas forcément des problèmes quelle que
soit la solution qu'on cherche vous en
tant qu'expert en maîtrise de l'énergie
en quel type d'énergie renouvelable vous
croyez pour pour demain
écoutez il y en a plusieurs et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que il a
plusieurs et les se complète entre elles
donc pour la production d'électricité
hydraulique est déjà importante en
france peut-être qu'on peut augmenter un
peu mais et ça c'est vraiment déjà un
avantage qui est acquis qui permet
d'ailleurs de compenser d'aider des
variations des autres il ya l'éolien
l'éolien terrestre est actuellement pas
moins cher le nouveau nucléaire donc il
faudrait développer sérieusement
l'éolien terrestre en particulier par
des financements citoyens fin des
méthodes qui font que les gens sont
impliqués dans dans la mise en place des
éoliennes dans le photovoltaïque qui est
très intéressant puisque vous produisez
directement de l'électricité dans quinze
ans sans aucune transformation et là
aussi on a un retard considérable donc
il faut que des efforts compris du point
de vue financement pour développer le
photovoltaïque
et puis à la biomasse qui est le bois le
bois les toutes les déchets etc qui est
surtout intéressante pour la production
de chaleur et en particulier pour
remplacer autant que possible le
chauffage électrique qui est une
aberration à tout point de vue
énergétique
financiers etc et donc vous avez 7 et la
géothermie en particulier dans le bassin
parisien ce qui est pas mal utilisé mais
qui pourraient être développés également
pour la chaleur france est le pays
pratiquement le pays le plus riche en
énergies renouvelables en europe puisque
on a à la fois les on a toutes ces
énergies que j'ai cités en grande
quantité et il ya même maintenant des
choses qui démarre dans les énergies
marines c'est à dire les grands les
courants marins et les vagues pour vous
c'est véritablement la clé économie
d'énergie
économie d'énergie économie
d'électricité
on gaspille l'électricité dans les
bâtiments c'est au niveau de l'éclairage
et surtout de ce qu'on appelle les
usages spécifiques c'est à l'éclairage
électroménager l'audiovisuel
l'informatique on consomme beaucoup trop
et là on a un potentiel d'économies
d'énergie
d'électricité considérables et c'est la
clé pour vraiment débloqué la situation
et vous est ce m franchement sur la
transition énergétique si la france est
à la traîne elle perdra énormément à la
fois sur le plan environnemental et sur
le plan économique et donc le problème
c'est de prendre des décisions et de
donner les moyens de se mettre vraiment
sur cette trajectoire la trajectoire
plus ou moins tracé mais les moyens sont
pas claires il ya rien de pire si vous
voulez d'annoncer des objectifs et de
pas dire bombe par rapport à tel
objectif voilà les moyens qui sont mis
en place et on démarre et là ça traîne
et c'est très dommage pas pas du tout
pour des raisons intellectuelles mais
c'est très dommage à la fois pour
l'environnement et pour les
consommateurs merci beaucoup mais sur la
planche pour supplications merci c'est
moi qui vous remercie
nous venons de le voir avec monsieur
laponche l'énergie de demain coûtera
cher certains l'ont bien compris et
n'hésitent pas à rénover leur habitat
afin d'éviter de futures factures
énergétiques salé et de préserver
l'environnement malgré tout cela reste
onéreux reportage
antoine désir habite à magny les hameaux
en trois ans il a transformé son simple
pavillon de banlieue en maisons passives
aussi appelée maison sans chauffage le
principe d'une maison passive c'est
qu'on profite des apports du soleil et
des apports internes par exemple
mi-temps pour chauffer la maison et donc
pour ça le principe c'est de ne pas
perdre de chaleur à travers les murs par
exemple et donc il faut beaucoup
l'isoler et chez antoine désir tout a
été rénové pour devenir passif en
isolation extérieure est assurée avec
des blocs de 50 cm de polystyrène
graphite est collée au mur au sous sol
c'est du polyuréthane qui recouvre le
plafond et une partie des murs les
fenêtres sont en triple vitrage et
permettent une grande étanchéité à l'air
pour le toit c'est plus écologique dans
le choix des matériaux ouate de
cellulose et fibre de bois aujourd'hui
féminin dréno lors il fait 22 degrés
dedans et il n'y a pas de chauffage
chauffage qui de toute façon et d'une
puissance très faible 1 du maison comme
ça dans le détail on utilise les
serviettes mais salle de bain pour
antoine désir ne s'est pas arrêté à
l'isolation 40 tubes solaires sont
installés sur le toit pour chauffer
l'eau des panneaux photovoltaïques et
servent à l'auto consommation
d'électricité le clou de sa rénovation
c'est son système de ventilation double
flux qui récupère toute la chaleur
intérieure de la maison cette chaleur
est conservée mélangé à l'air qui vient
de l'extérieur est renvoyé dans la
maison qui est donc chauffer
gratuitement qui est intéressant dans ce
progrès avec la maison à la base et
maison très conventionnel de ça peut
concerner un peu tout le monde qu'un
pavillon c'est vrai qu'il ya dix ans
vous n'avez quasiment aucun projet de ce
type là ni écologique ni passif ni bbc
est aujourd'hui en action le territoire
du parc naturel régional qui représente
soit quand une commune de nombreux
projets qui sont réalisés ou qui sont en
train d'émerger ce type de construction
permet à long terme des économies
antoine désir a vu sa facture
d'électricité de 2500 euros par an / 5
mais cela reste une histoire de passion
écologique pour sa maison le magnet quoi
à débourser pas moins de deux cent
cinquante mille euros crédit d'impôt
inclus
monsieur santi et bonjour merci ne
recevoir ici à la maison de
l'environnement on vient de voir un
sujet sur une maison passive qui a été
rénové à magny les hameaux chez monsieur
désir alors justement pour rénover sa
maison quels sont aujourd'hui les
dispositions à prendre et surtout les
pièges à éviter alors les pièges à
éviter la première chose c'est pour
pouvoir quand on veut rénover sa maison
ses deux d'avoir une vision globale
des travaux qu'il faudrait réaliser
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas se ruer sur
le premier professionnel qui passe qui
vous dit il faut changer les fenêtres ou
faut isoler ses murs il va certainement
vous donner des bons arguments qui
seront très certainement vrai la seule
chose c'est qu'il faut ce qui est
important c'est de savoir par où
commencer en fait il faut prioriser ces
travaux puisque on sait que en fonction
de la configuration du logement il est
préférable de commencer par isoler la
toiture ou les murs ou changer ses
fenêtres ça dépend vraiment de la
configuration du logement donc il est
important d'avoir un conseil global de
façon à pouvoir effectivement choisir et
prioriser les travaux on passe au
financement aujourd'hui y at il des
aides financières des crédits d'impôt
pour les gens qui veulent passer à la
maison verte alors oui effectivement il
ya des aides regarde certaines aides qui
existent déjà depuis un certain temps
comme le crédit d'impôt donc le crédit
d'impôt qui encouragent en fait des
rénovations assez lourde c'est à dire où
on fait vraiment un des économies
d'énergie de façon assez importante
il ya l'éco prêt à taux zéro également
qu' pareil donc permet d'avoir du
financement pour ces travaux là il ya
également une nouvelle aide qui vient
d'arriver sur qui vient de sortir donc
c'est une aide de 1350 euros mais qui
est en fait sous conditions de
ressources c'est à dire que en fonction
de son revenu on peut bénéficier ou pas
de cette aide et puis également sous
condition de ressources il ya un grand
programme qui a été lancé depuis
quelques temps et qui est en train de se
mettre en place les conditions ont
changé récemment pour pouvoir toucher
plus de personnes c'est ce qu'on appelle
le programme habiter mieux donc qui
permet effectivement d'avoir un niveau
de subventions la très important ça peut
monter jusqu'à 80 % 2 de subventions
donc c'est vraiment très intéressant
c'est sous conditions de ressources
également sachant que les niveaux les
plafonds actuels font qu environ 60%
fier des personnes pourraient bénéficier
de ce programme habiter mieux donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très fort
voilà ça rentre dans la dans la volonté
du gouvernement la de rénover 500 mille
logements par an donc voila tout
investissement se rentabilise pas du
jour au lendemain mais bon en quelques
années sachant que l'on sait que les
énergies vont augmenter fortement voilà
ça ça sera rentable de toute façon à
terme ça c'est clair merci beaucoup pour
tout ces conseils pratiques monsieur
sentiers et à très bientôt à bientôt
mais réservé à
ces la fin de votre magazine sur
l'environnement mais avant de se quitter
place à la jda du 13 novembre au 28
décembre découvrez une exposition sur
l'eau et les hommes expérience à l'appui
venez découvrir ou redécouvrir que la
vie sur terre est apparu dans l'eau le
14 novembre emmenez vos enfants voire
puis une balade musicale jouant des
sonorités aquatique enfin le samedi 23
novembre une randonnée en forêt de
port-royal vous fera découvrir
l'écosystème forestier en observant sa
faune et sa flore nous on se retrouve le
22 novembre pour un nouveau numéro d'
équilibre à d'ici là n'oubliez pas la
terre est notre mère respectant la salle